[Music]
being embedded in this part of Japanese
culture seemed like a really fantastic
opportunity and one that will provide
the kind of knowledge that you can't get
from both
[Music]
the residences incredible opportunity
put for by British Council in
partnership with Issei city which is the
city where the most venerated Shinto
shrine in the whole world is and it's
given a group of artists from a variety
of disciplines across the UK the
opportunity to come and spend two weeks
really immersed in Shinto culture when I
approached the residency and the
thoughts have been immersed into a
different culture my first footing would
be do you think about shared
similarities between Japanese society
and culture and culture and society in
the UK and when we arrived it was an
immediate sense of wonder
[Music]
in Japanese music specifically there's a
very different approach to time but I
really wanted to try and find out how a
different approach to time might affect
the compositions I'm a alongside that
there was this aspect of Shinto that
seemed to speak about humans as being
part of nature in a way there was quite
different to the human nature divide
that we have in Western culture one of
the things that I was most joined to my
application was investigating the
physical and the sensory components of
worshipping at one of the Shinto shrines
and how our people who visit have an
experience of the divine and how they
feel that through their senses it's been
completely overwhelming it's felt like
just complete privilege the whole time
and you know I'm constantly feeling
thankful for being in this situation but
it also gives you this kind of pressure
in a good sense to really uncover all
you can and like in every situation I'm
in I find myself wanting to like look at
everything every little detail sometimes
as an artist you know you can kind of
get very insular and it is tough to kind
of you know to kind of broaden out and
your thinking and your experience but
often that's so powerful because it
really brings your work opportunities
like this are really important primarily
for dialogue and exchange actually so
one of the things for me is I can I can
read about these things I can also come
here on my own listen to things but
actually having the opportunity to speak
to people and get an understanding of
what it means to be provoked to live
here
International opportunities are
definitely important for artists there's
always the benefit of being able to look
again at your own culture or your own
local grounding from a slightly
different perspective people are so
generous in wanting to tell you things
even if you can't communicate directly
people want to show you things because
they want to communicate the things that
they think are unique my personal
challenge to myself is to communicate to
the dancers and musicians and set
designers I work with all of the
magnificent wonderful experiences I've
had here it's been incredibly beautiful
amazing to see such tradition in
operation but also such kind of forward
future thinking actually after a while
more that you start to kind of
experience just being here and certainly
the ritual that happened last night in
terms of the harvest and and welcoming
the rice I think it became something so
powerful about a notion of something
that's not always about the visible or
the verbal but it's always about
something that's not necessarily said
being immersed in the culture here has
had some like really satisfying
mismatches especially in moments when
we've been talking about concepts that
don't have direct translations or that
you kind of get through experience there
really just is nothing like immersion
for learning anything and this has been
kind of constant learning for two weeks
[Music]
you